loja reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna watch a video
from Screen Rant Marvel's original MCU
plan would have made Avengers endgame
very different I'm curious to know what
they have to say before we do that I
want to say thank you to everyone who
has downloaded and Followill songs the
sawdust up over there but you thirty
second reaction reviews for films TV
shows and or trailers sometimes they're
micro sketches we post daily it's free
to download free to use like Costco
samples except more beneficial do today
marvel marvel marvel marvel characters
in movie history but they could have
been very different the way in which
their stories been told in the franchise
please to a meticulously planned long
term idea but that's actually far from
being true in fact of truth be told the
MCU and its flagship team of heroes are
a prime example of how last-minute
changes unforeseen obstacles
improvisation off the tough decisions
and freewheeling can actually
emphatically work out for the best in
this video will outline exactly what me
didn't have 22 scripts ready which will
have given us very different Avengers
the entire lead-up to the Avengers we
now have in the MCU and indeed the
stories they've been involved and have
all stemmed from changes to the original
plan even that now iconic Avengers
mid-credits teaser and it was a
last-minute decision by director Joss
Whedon who had no idea where I would
eventually leave because wow you do have
a master bad waters remember my Haddon
didn't know that stone wasn't made
concrete until years later and that
resulted in a number of random pieces of
the MCU jigsaw having to be read climbed
for example the tesseract wasn't
originally meant to be the space stone
but even before that Marvel Studios had
played a game of trial and error with
regards to the way their Avengers and
would unfold on screen of course the
ultimate plan for phase 1 of the MCU is
always to bring the Avengers together
but the first Avengers movie had an
initial release date set for 2011 before
it was pushed back a year moreover what
Earth's Mightiest Heroes could have
looks like was almost very different
both in terms of the teams lineup and
the actors who'd be portraying them the
first real tease of the plan to form an
Avengers team the MCU was of course in
that famous post-credit scene from 2008
Iron Man 1 Samuel Jackson Nick Fury
turned up at Tony Stark's Malibu mansion
to talk about the idea but the movie
itself was deceptively standalone with
only a running gag about shields
long-winded full name being the only
real hint at a wider universe but that
post-credits tease really was nothing
more than that at ease and believe it or
not just like the mid-credits scene of
The Avengers in which Thanos debuted
four years later he was actually
something of a last-minute decision to
include and I work to ensure sankarea
plans to expand upon it but anyone who
thought the scene was nothing more than
a cheap nod to comics was quickly proven
wrong because a mere a couple of months
later in the Incredible Hulk spree
credits tease Tony Stark approached
William Hertz general Ross about the
team he was putting together the outline
of the early ideas for the team could
clearly be seen by this point Tony Stark
was brought in to lead the team possibly
to track down the AWOL halt in what
would have been a very similar story to
the Avengers number one comic book from
1963 that first issue saw loki
attempting to escape exile by
manipulating the green Goliath into
accidentally destroying a bridge what
was teased Avengers wise in the early
days of the MCU was actually very
different to what we eventually got
stark was deemed unsuitable for the team
until shield had no other choice but to
bring him in while the Hulk was a
completely different character by 2012
in more ways than one not only was the
early Avengers blueprint hurtling
towards a different story
there were also different actors in some
of the key roles Mark Ruffalo became
Bruce Banner and Hulk after Edward
Norton famously had a difference of
creative opinion with Marvel Studios
which in turn served as a way of
conveniently distancing the MCU from The
Incredible Hulk movie which Marvel
Studios seemed intent
doing not a dispute with a studio
Terrence Howard was replaced as James
war machine Rhodes my dog Cheadle from
2010's Iron Man 2 onward Scarlett
Johansson has played Natasha Romanoff
the Black Widow since Iron Man 2 but it
was Emily Blunt who was originally set
to star as the character John Breaux
drilling first to Iron Man movies and
famously plays happy Hogan in the MCU
had her down as his first choice but she
had to quit before she even got started
when Fox exercised the contract clause
from The Devil Wears Prada to have her
star in Gulliver's Travels she looks at
what a phenomenon the MCU has become
well none of these changes had the level
of impacts that James - personnel behind
the cameras had they did play something
of a part in reshaping how the MCU could
have developed Iron Man 2 is the movie
that marks the point in which the NSC
whose original phase 1 plan notably
veered off track Tony Stark's arc
changed course dramatically as Natasha
Romanov assessed his suitability for the
Avengers and ultimately came to the
conclusion that he wasn't fit for
purpose it seemingly created something
of a plot hole by contradicting the
credits scenes in both of the previous
movies in the MCU Iron Man and The
Incredible Hulk but the plot wall was
suitably filled by the Marvel one-shots
short movie the consultant in 2011 which
explained that stark approaching Ross
was actually a ploy by shield to trick
the general into keeping abomination
locked up in fact post movie retcons
like these were quite commonplace until
the early days of phase 2 of the
franchise when Thor rose alesha at 11
amidst aspects of the avengers that were
consistent with the team we ended up
with we're starting to be introduced but
that didn't mean there wasn't still some
confusion the post-credits scene had
Erik Selvig chatting with Nick Fury deep
within project Pegasus about working on
the tesseract when they presumed dead
Loki appeared in a reflection
controlling stellan skarsgård character
well Tom Hiddleston's character did go
on to mind-control Selvig and while the
tesseract was a key part of the first
Avengers offering the fact that the god
of mischief was already on earth
completely contradicted the manner of
his introduction in the team up movie
Captain America the First Avenger
however which was released just a couple
of months after Thor in the same year
was all rather cohesive with the rest of
the expanding MCU
but somewhat convoluted changes that
were made to the franchise however such
as Tony Stark
recruited in the first act of the
Avengers just like being turned down by
the team in this previous MCU appearance
we're due to changes that occurred
behind the scenes x2 and x-men Last
Stand writers at pad had been working on
a script for the Avengers since 2006 but
he's been forced to make constant
adjustments as directors enacted
influence and characters began to fully
form as a result alterations were made
to both characters and the story
especially with regards to Tony Stark
and his first draft was submitted to
Marvel Studios in early 2010 but
everything changed when the Avengers
found its director Joss Whedon was
extremly dismissive of Penn's worship
saying there was a script there's the
script I was going to fill a word of its
not know exactly what Penn script
entailed but it's believed it involved
the Red Skull and Whedon's alterations
made what he did with Justice League
look of minor in comparison the
fundamentals of Whedon's amended script
were simple did your team of superheroes
would go up against Tom Hill Stan's Loki
fighting amongst themselves along the
way and it would culminate in an epic
battle against the god of mischief and
his army at the end it's probably fair
to assume that the brief we did was
given to work with was similar to that
of tanks the final Avengers movie wasn't
too dissimilar to the after mentioned
comic The Avengers number one after all
and all the narrative drive was
different this pretend very similar DNA
to the one he'd previously dismissed but
the main problem Whedon hadn't the
initial script wasn't the story it was
its character and spark he believed
Penn's vision lacked chemistry as far as
the relationships between the titular
heroes were concerned there was a time
for example when the poorly written
terms and Scarlett Johansson's Ironman
to contract mentioned had not returned
for the movies some one version of the
script had a key role for the wasp
written into it wasp is of course a
founding member of the Avengers in the
comics and she would have provided the
team with a feminine touch in black
widows absence that obviously never
happened if the impact on the MCU as a
whole it would have been a huge the dead
black widows absence would have needed
explaining janitor hope Van Dyne would
have been introduced to the franchise
three years ahead of ant-man
would have completely altered the story
of that ant-man movie and you're saying
it was still going to be held by Edgar
Wright there was another draft that saw
Loki teaming up with Ezekiel Stane we
have bridges Obadiah
Ironman due to Whedon's concerns about
whether or not Tom Hiddleston could
carry the villainous mantle alone and
the fact he wasn't convinced by the idea
placing so much attention on Thor the
problem is this would have run the risk
of making it feel more like Ironman
two-point-five than an Avengers movie
Captain America's role in the movie was
also adjusted I'll be an admirer
fashioned quite late in the day but we
saw him becoming the team's undisputed
leader but several scenes were cut from
the start of the movie that would have
emphasized him more as a man out of time
it was probably due to the fact that the
First Avenger hadn't brought in a
particularly impressive sum at the box
office so being more careful with the
character was deemed the save option
until he was really in the thick of the
Avengers action of course different
actors would have resulted in different
stories - Terrence Howard reappeared or
machine would have had a major role in
the Avengers given the fact that his
initial Iron Man deal had him as the
star Edward Norton is really more
creative control into given the whole a
bigger role but his chemistry with the
other actors probably wouldn't have been
as good as Mark Ruffalo's which would
have limited what could have been done
regarding Hulk and Bruce Banner driven
character stories a major influence of
Whedon script changes however were on
the actual tone of the MCU that Whedon s
humor has now become known as MCU humor
and any brief attempts to diverge from
it in the franchise such as with Shane
black at the helm of Iron Man 3 works
really received very well James Gunn has
since exemplified that MCU humor notion
with a very similar quirky sense of fun
in his guardians of the galaxy movies
the Infinity Gauntlet comic book arc is
certainly a story that was always a
potentially prime source for inspiration
in the franchise but it didn't become
the planned endgame no pun intended
until the first Avengers movie and the
unplanned decision to include the drew
moon despot in the mid credit scene the
red cons required to bet him into the
Infinity Saga
after that make the road to the Avengers
look meticulously planned over a long
period but it certainly wasn't Ironman
was a dance and it's crazy
that's crazy and when the time came to
assemble the Avengers the franchise was
popular enough that the unprecedented
idea had a great chance of working
but that popularity certainly didn't
stem from an orchestrated master plan
Marvel Studios went into a lot of their
ventures completely blind and in spite
of all the time talented hard work
that's gone into it the inconsistencies
are still clear to see if you look hard
enough what do you think of this video
well the MCU have been better or worse
at the original plans for the event and
game makes it look like it's perfect a
really they had this mapped out for the
beginning it's like any game really
makes the whole plan feel like full
circle even back to the first Ironman in
a way I mean with the point they're
making here about you know using
different directors you know a little
creative flourishes that kind of changes
the shape of the story I feel like
endgame in a way exemplifies that even
more in the way that it goes back and
touches on previous movies that needed
tying up or that needed acknowledgement
for certain things they've proven
themselves very conscientious with how
they've handled this the series what
this video really really remind me of
the powerful influence Joss Whedon has
played over the entire MCU and it's kind
of sad how much Joss Whedon has pretty
much distance himself from Marvel ever
since all the abl age Voltron crap that
went down which is crazy too because not
only is his humor and his sensibility a
really apparent in the MCU but it's also
through the success of the MCU impacted
so many of the movies now the Joss
Whedon humor has essentially become the
Marvel brand humor because that really
became defined with Avengers Assemble
and I remember phase 1 being kind of
rocky when people would make digs it's
like what's been going on with Star Wars
and how it's had some missteps or even
the DC Universe I'm like Marvel wasn't
perfect at first they had the benefit
that the first Ironman was [ __ ]
amazing credible Hulk is rather
forgettable now Iron Man 2 Captain
America was underwhelming for a lot of
people 3 was that some mixed react
seems like iron is a great one and then
everything from phase one up until
Avengers is like pretty good yeah okay
you know I did learn some interesting
stuff here I mean with the Ironman one
post-credit scene how they put it was
that it was sort of a last-minute
addition that they wanted to throw on
there and they didn't have big plans to
expand it
they had a hull coming out later I
imagine they probably shot that like you
might as well just throw it on there and
then it seems like since the post-credit
things seem to really take off and
create all this hype and anticipation
that it drastically reshaped Meyer Man 2
which was met with a lot of criticism
okay now they're doing the whole setup
for the Avengers way too much in my face
now as opposed to little trinkets here
there and then a post-credits scene now
it seemed like you the Marvel's heads
were like oh damn we really got
something here with this Avenger seeds
let's really capitalize on it well
that's the funny thing to me about
looking back over the MCU because there
are certain things that are really
surprising to know weren't pre-planned
but overall and more I think about just
the journey we've all been on phase one
especially does feel like a studio of
figuring out what their plan is and have
that first mega success with Iron Man
but then you know it takes kind of till
the Avengers to really repeat that I
find it fascinating the way you can kind
of track that because yet there feels
like a certain point in the MCU and I'm
not sure really what film to put it on
other than maybe the Avengers where they
do sort of find what I feel like is
their longer-term plan for a lot of it
you know I I appreciate that you know it
is kind of a living little universe that
can be affected by different people and
that will cause it to change over time
well I think it's important that they
don't map out too far in advance I feel
like what they got as a guideline but
it's not a you know a Holy Bible that
they gotta live by in order to make sure
that it goes this very specific way each
and every time like it doesn't surprise
me that they've had to improvise
constantly or readjust or reevaluate
their strategy just make sense of why it
works so well that's more the entire MCU
overall you know very adaptive I think
the thing it took me for a loop the most
somehow I completely missed
information that Thanos was just a fun
little sting that we'd him throughout
there but it really didn't have plans
but it led to the culmination of the MC
in led to it oh yeah was so it's just so
funny to me I'm like oh yeah I could
have sworn that was like their master
plan from the get-go
you know going back to what you said
earlier about the bummer of the fact
that Joss Whedon has distanced himself
so much it's like now ever since that
little post-credits ding so much of the
arc of the whole saga has stemmed from
this one the randomise little tenuous
things like that are fascinating to me
because it could have just as easily not
happen because I know that wasn't Josh
Brolin I I know that Josh Brolin at the
end of Avengers Assemble same time it's
like wow the the influence Joss Whedon
has had but now his name isn't really
associated it's like you hear Joss
Whedon you think of Marvel but when you
think of Marvel you don't think of Joss
Whedon no the Avengers yeah you think of
the Russos the Russo's wouldn't have had
infinity war an end game if it wasn't
for what Joss Whedon did he became the
guy who's helped shape it but then the
guy who's also given us the worst
Avengers movie yeah they're only as good
as your last thing you did and the last
thing he did for Marvel was age of
Ultron it just seems like that's the
stamp that everyone remembers him by
this video really brought to light like
damn it'd be kind of cool if you brought
waited back for like one more random
thing if he was able to come back with
like you know good graces with these
guys there was an agreeable scenario
there'd be fun man and there's some
other fun things were in here like Emily
Blunt who's gonna be Black Widow dammit
great casting I think Scarlett Johansson
has really made her stamp on the
character I think Emily bow would have
worked just as well you know and she
would have brought a whole different you
know acting sensibility to it you know
definitely yes yeah family I mean Emily
Blunt is one of my favorite actors in
general to working today and she's
proven her diversity and she's pretty
she could do action with things like
everyone references edges tomorrow or
even Sicario you kind of combine both
you can get a black widow character so
yeah Emily plum would have been a
fantastic pick I'm satisfied with the
black widow die here there's film in the
Black Widow movie I think I saw set
photos yeah and actually Emily Blunt is
gonna be scar yeah
they were talking about how an gate
would have been totally different but it
doesn't see what they had endgame in
mind in game it would've been this is
more surrounding Avengers Assemble if
anything and how Avengers Assemble
affected the trajectory of what the MCU
would culminate into but like having the
wasp as an early edition and introducing
before ant-man that would have changed a
MCU that would have also changed ant-man
and in total because she doesn't even
become the wasp in the first ant-man
movie no no yeah and then I'm thinking
like if they have the wasp as part of
the team would we have met Scott Lang in
that movie is some kind of weird Easter
egg supporting characters related I've
been Evangeline Lilly yeah like someone
differed have been like the wasp
character would have been totally
different and as part of being an
Avengers character she still hasn't made
her stamp as part of the team yet yeah
like she participates at the end fight
of endgame but she's not you know known
as one of the faces of the event one of
the marble faces but she's not one of
the faces of the Avengers at least to
the you know the public sphere I know
there's a technicality and semantics and
yada yada yada but you know I'm getting
at for somebody out there she is the
face I didn't know Zak Penn was also the
guy who penned the first draft four
years and because his name is Penn or a
guy I know
years on that ship that quote from Joss
Whedon is true I'm like man that [ __ ]
keep it in my bathroom now so I can save
on toilet I mean you didn't have that in
mind but dude exact Ben was he's they're
saying yet to work off of the constant
rewrites and the influences and input of
what the other directors were doing with
their films over time yeah I can't help
but imagine he was like man come on I
just want you to do your thing everybody
came in here way late man I've been
working on this thing since the
beginning
like every time a movie comes out I
gotta change the whole thing I don't
know if that's what yeah is that a
buddy's summary of a sentiment or
something yeah in a way that's still a
bummer for the guy cuz no one associates
Avengers Assemble Woods
this is true such above it's part of
Hollywood making money it seems like he
writes yeah worked on the x-men films
and stuff this is a fascinating video
this is really really interesting expert
class and yes anding absolutely global
escape oh yeah alright guys well go
subscribe to Screen Rant if you haven't
done so already check out more of their
videos especially Ryan George's pitch
meeting is one of my favorite segments
on YouTube they have ever existed you
can subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell if you like
this video hit that thumbs up button
implying positivity and before at this
video up I want to get a patron of the
day shot so a lovely woman named a Delia
Chamberlain I mentioned this in a video
recent that wasn't Avengers related so I
feel like it's best to mention it again
she wrote this wonderful article about
the psychology of the characters in
Avengers endgame how pretty much that
whole art is all of them portraying
different elements of grief and it's
beautifully done and it certainly
affected my 3rd time watching Avengers
endgame and I was really seeing a lot of
what she had brought to my attention so
I would highly recommend you guys go
check out that article there's a link in
the description box and on a side note
she's reading
I think she's read all the Game of
Thrones books and she's just about to
start Game of Thrones oh oh get ready
for that ready for a satisfying
conclusion already or and my dear all
those years of reading or about to be
justified oh yeah see you guys